عادت الضفه الغربيه منذ اكثر من عامين
لتكون منطلقه عمليات المقاومه ضد الاحتلال
ومعها عاده التشكيلات العسكريه منها ما هو
مندرج في اطار الفصائل الفلسطينيه
المعروفه بعملها المقاوم ومنها ما هو جديد
لا يتبع اي فصيل مجموعه عارين الاسود تتخذ
من البلده القديمه في نابلس نقطه انطلاق
رئيسيه لها لا يمكن تحديد موعد انطلاقها
او من يدعمها بشكل حاسم لكنها شكلت حاله
مختلفه عن المجموعات المقاومه في الضفه لا
يتبع عناصرها اي فصيل فلسطيني معروف تمتاز
بقدره عاليه على قياده وتنظيم مراحل
الاشتباك المباشر مع جيش الاحتلال
الى الشمال من نابلس تبقى مدينه جنين
ومخيمها في دائره المواجهه لتجدد خلايا
مقاومه تابعه للفصائل عملها في المدينه
والمخيم وابرسها كتيبه جنين تتبع سرايا
القدس الجناح العسكريه لحركه الجهاد
الاسلامي كتيبه العياش التي تقول انها
تابعه لكتائب عز الدين القسام الجناح
العسكري لحركه حماس ولفت قبل اسبوعين
تقريبا اعلان كتيبه العياش اطلاق صاروخي
قسام واحد من مدينه جنين نحو مستوطنه شكيب
في عمليه ليست الاولى من نوعها في جنين
ايضا تنشط كتائب شهداء الاقصى التابعه
لحركه فتح بالانتقال الى طول كارم تنشط
كتيبه طولكرم التابعه لسرايا القدس ويبرز
نشاطها في مخيم نور شمس حيث تبنت الكتيبه
تفجير محليه الصنع في اليات عسكريه
اسرائيليه وايضا كتيبه طولكرم الرد السريع
التابعه لشهداء الاقصى والاحدث في عمليات
المقاومه ما شهدته اريحا التي تدرس فيها
كتيبه عقبه جبر التابعه لسرايا القدس
وكتيبه مخيم عقبه جبر التابعه لكتائب
القسام تعمل هذه الفصائل جميعها في ظل
ظروف امنيه معقده في الضفه الغربيه هناك
تسيطر اسرائيل امنيا على كل شيء تقريبا
يستطيع جنودها اقتحام اي مكان في اي وقت
ويتهم فلسطينيون اجهزه امن السلطه
الفلسطينيه للتنسيق بشكل لصق مع قوه
الاحتلال في اطار ما يسمى التنسيق الامني
وخلال الاسابيع القليله الماضيه اتهمت عده
فصائل السلطه
باعتقال مقاومين والتحقيق معهم بينما
تتذرع الاجهزه الامنيه بان هذه الاعتقالات
هي توقيفات تتم وفق القانون سعيا لمواجهه
ما تسميه السلطه
يضاف الى ذلك التطبيقات التي تمنع وصول
امدادات السلاح الى فصائل المقاومه لتاتي
المفاجاه على لسان قاده في جيش الاحتلال
بان اسلحه هجوميه باتت تصنع في مناطق عده
في الضفه الغربيه
[موسيقى]